all right guys today is a very very very
exciting Day Jesus what don't do that to
them what you don't think I'm handsome
huh I know your trick huh huh huh well
right behind M bear is color marble CMI
and I'm a big fan of these guys and you
might be like what do you mean you're a
big fan of this company I'm a big fan of
it because remember our first I would
say maybe our ninth forever home in
Vegas so remember that big B old
fireplace and we got that whole thing
laid out and we got what they call was
it called a big yeah Panda which means
it's black and white also it's like
bookended right so these were the only
guys that had the inventory where we can
get all the marble matched up and it
lined up perfectly black was black so
super high quality because all of the
other ones that we saw it was more on
the green the black was more on the
green side where these guys it was clear
and it was black and it was like this is
when we were working with an interior
designer so she was giving us all the
like ins and outs of what to do the good
good so she was like this is it this is
the spot so I'm not trying to speak out
of my ass I'm speaking from an expert
who told me um and I'm like okay these
guys are the real deal yeah cuz marble
what you're looking for you don't want
it to be veiny in other aspects of life
you want to be as veiny as possible you
know what I'm
saying but yeah you don't want to be
veiny cuz that means that looks dirty
right when it's like white and black and
you have white veins running through the
black and you have like green veins
running through the white doesn't look
good you want to be as sharp as possible
and our our interior designer she
designs casinos so she brought us to the
good good suppliers and even they and
billionaire homes and billionaire homes
so she couldn't uh we couldn't find
something that we liked but these guys
they had it so now it's time for our
45th forever home home in Vegas in Vegas
and they reached out to us and like yo
how about we do a promotion where we
hook you up with some materials and then
you guys Vlog about it talk about I'm
like uh duh of course that's what I
wanted to do the first time so I'll take
you I'll bring you guys through the
facility you guys can take a look I know
there's a lot of people that are our age
got homes are looking into interior
design whether you want tile marble
other types of masonry they got it and
they're out here in
California it's color marble okay
CMI in case you're Wonder in and they
got a showroom and these are the
showroom hours which is pretty
convenient I know a lot of people are
busy but the fact that they're even open
on a Saturday which is really really
cool cuz you know a lot of us you work
Monday through Friday and the only times
we can get stuff done like for the
extracurricular stuff like our homes is
the weekend to run errands so not only
is the showroom open but also the
warehouse Sunday they would like to take
a break which is perfectly acceptable
all right check this out I already like
what I see because I like when people
put their money where the mouth is you
know what I'm saying like they're just
straight up here's this rest area and
we're going to make it out of this crazy
ass material I don't even know if it's
Marble or quartz or I don't know
anything Granite what whatever they call
it this is tight but this is just
straight up oh yeah they just got they
use it as an artwork just on the wall
which is pretty damn too I'm pretty sure
this is theirs all right this tile
just some crazy ass
materials look at this just straight up
Stone just straight Stone you know what
I'm
saying it's been it's been uh it's been
really cool to see uh this collaboration
go through yeah I know it's been a
little this is Andrew from color marel
what's your what's your position here uh
I run the show here so I mean it's not
easy but uh yeah it's me it's just me
and then a great team of a great team of
here so hello that that's louw and then
yeah we'll show you a little bit of
everybody we go on but yeah this is
color Marvel and uh yeah um basically
yeah when you mentioned to me in the
email you know suzan and all that stuff
that's my mom so my mom uh just recently
just recently she decided to retire La
last year the end of last year so um
this past year we just been through
going through all the change of
ownership so it's a lot of paperwork and
a lot of uh lot of serious stuff that I
didn't I didn't know it was like that
but I'm glad that we're going through
that now so that you know we can get
ready for the future hell yeah yeah yeah
so it's all good um but yeah so this is
how we started in 1991 um actually this
location so um everything everything you
see now is is all remodeled and it's wow
so you guys never moved you just stayed
here and just expanded this one and
Alhambra and Alhambra so so this one we
we've been here since
1991 and then um here we are today wow
so uh just in the past since I started
probably like six years ago we just went
through a lot of changing just a lot of
changing in terms of operation obviously
marketing too um and just changing
changing overall leadership so uh that's
what we've been doing the past six years
and just trying to see how we can break
ground into our industry better I see
cuz before we we we were just selling
just door too wholesaling but uh since
the introduction of color course and
then we found out that wow we can
actually build Brands out of our own
products so that's what we've been doing
now and that's what we're going to try
to continue to do so obviously color
quarts is one of our best products that
is all it's worldwide known now but now
we want to see if we can do it with
color color marble see if we can make
color marble the brand that um everybody
can go to eventually so so that's where
we are now so just a few remodels that
we've done obviously we've changed um
just a few uh things in terms of terms
of exterior we did a lot of remodeling
in terms of like the Walling exploding
all that stuff so um this is color
Marvel now this is our new warehouse
today is that here yeah that's here so
uh we we knew that cuz we knew that our
competitors they all have these dim
lightings and when you warehous it's
hard to see the material so we wanted to
really invest in lighting so that you
know customers can see really how
beautiful I like how everything's white
too cuz like the colors pop out like
yeah exactly yeah yeah so you want to
make everything white everything light
um just so if even if it's raining or if
it's too too much sun there's always
good Lighting in in our place cuz
lighting is very important yes yeah so
um and in terms of how we want to
showcase our slabs we we we always want
to try to Showcase a book match so even
though it takes up more space we want to
show all the slabs and which like for
example the way you guys did your
fireplace which was amazing so you you
know they can do you know book match
vertical horizontal all sh to you guys
cuz we look all over for real we went to
like maybe four or five suppliers and
they even do the casinos yeah and we it
was hard to find like the full length
book match it's funny you should yeah I
mean you have whoever is your interior
designer they really caught the trend
because that that that color is sold out
right now everybody wants that color
right now Panda everybody wants that
right now so they c a Trend so yeah
we'll show you we'll show you what the
trends are following that Trend so
that's how fast the market is but so
we'll show you um but yeah this is where
we are today color Marvel but everything
you see so this is a really awesome
greeting like you guys got some of the
insight as to what they do some stuff
that you didn't catch um that he did say
off camera was that a lot of this stuff
not only can go in residential it can
also go in businesses it can go in like
hospitals and they do a lot a lot a lot
of different testing to get very
specific certifications so if you own a
business um
where you know your materials are super
sensitive and you need to have certain
certificates in order to place these
materials on your walls then this is the
spot to check out um as we walked in
here he was like Hey I already printed
out some of the stuff that you guys sent
me over in terms of your guys' mood
board this is some of the stuff that I
wanted um and it's pretty cool that you
know they already had such a wonderful
presentation for us to make it super
thoughtless where it's already printed
out and I can kind of start like
comparing and contrasting and kind of
like going and going like okay how do I
feel about this where would this go and
now we can start like the really fun
creative process I like that it's laid
out because you can hit the ground
running yes versus like okay so what did
you want again they start pulling it out
was it this was it that but it's now
it's like boom and then now we could get
creative immediately yes so another
thing that did help this process at
least for me was um just generally
starting with a with a p Pinterest mood
board so as you can see here I already
have different textures of walls that I
was kind of considering I didn't really
consult you too much but you were just
like run with it it's fine it cuz you
got Ste so that's why I was like if I
want a nice bathroom I have to marry you
sometimes um but yeah it was cool to
have this because now I can walk in here
and be like okay these are some things
that I'm considering um so now when I
see this I'm like wo this is really cool
because a picture can only do so much
right yeah and you can see these
swatches are a lot bigger which is
really really neat cuz normally I'm used
to seeing stuff like this size and I'm
like I don't know what to do with that
but this is really cool po this one what
do you like about it it's like porous
looking or looks like yeah so what I'm
considering so I like oh this looks like
that huh it does so I like this thing
called I mean this is Pinterest calling
it again I'm not an interior designer so
I don't know what I'm talking about but
the style that I'm really to right now
um is called modern organic so it looks
kind of Bohemian but it also looks very
modern where it has like the really like
clean cuts or what's the other one Japan
oh is another style that I like so this
is kind of hitting those tones this one
I really like because it just has a lot
of texture and right now what we're
trying to look for is our bedroom and oh
here and our living room and our living
room which I'm very grateful for look at
little bucket looks like this yeah so
that's the living room shout outs to
Rich Bri I know that's and then this is
the bedroom bedroom yep so bedroom I was
considering something a little bit more
Moody if you remember I mentioned I want
something more moody in there so so it
brings the energy down yeah kind of
tones it down we can calm down relax
relx chill um so I might have to change
something here but in terms of the
living room because we do have wood
elements and it is very bright and
vibrant well I don't know if it's
vibrant but it is very bright you got
that new six
chandelier yes um did I do want to bring
more Earth element in there so we do
have like wood beams we do have wooden
um what is it like the uh pendant
lighting yeah so like something like
this would be nice here or this
something more earthy looking yeah I
don't want it too so so of course
obviously yeah it's the it's the stone
that everyone wants to use right now
because there's no upkeep and and
usually the trends and styles can
replicate Natural Stone now pretty much
yeah pretty much yeah I've seen some so
yeah we're in the warehouse now and yes
it's very bright the lighting is insane
and you feel like like at some of the
other places I've been to I would want
to bring like the stone out in the Under
the Sun to get a accurate view but you
don't feel like you need that here like
everything that I'm looking at I'm like
oh that's exactly what color that is
like look that's exactly what color that
is because literally it is under the Sun
what a dope Warehouse showroom you great
for um uh like a backyard table backyard
table so a lot of people a lot of people
are trying to so we're trying to test
these out cuz um it looks so real it
looks like wood it looks really good
that actually looks really cool and it's
going to be way easy to up cuz not W one
of our other houses crazy and our dogs
are scratched it up around like we're
never doing real wood on FL do you think
again do you think you guys could use
this in your
house no no not at this point like if we
were barely moving in possibly but now
everything ceiling
yeah no I was going to say if you guys
have if you guys have well I mean I'm
going to do it right if you guys have
extra people want the slab with the
picture really they want the picture
with the slab they asked for everything
with so we we actually made a few of
these actually that's so cool custom
shout out the thatch they want the slab
with the picture hey so is this the
exact piece yeah this is the similar one
can't be the exact
piece this this triple now it's triple
now wow fob is triple so landed here is
crazy now W fob is triple now so that's
pretty cool yeah yeah yeah you guys you
guys really found a good one you guys
really got a good one this is this is
the hottest Stone right now one of the
hottest
wow we should move back into that house
then of our of our industry anini is
like the LV of Industry well they are
the yeah they are the LPM Mar industry
so um they only choose a few suppliers
around the world to carry their stuff
that they trust and we and we we so how
much is that like 100 Grand or something
no no the prices don't get up to but
something like this uh this is the
hottest St right now this is the hottest
St right now so uh every Tiffany store
you see every Tiffany store uses this
Stone so every uh South Coast Plaza the
one in New York they all use this Stone
anini huh I don't even know so this one
will run you about 8 to 10,000 a slab
wow 8 to 10,000 yeah I'm I'm too poor
for this kind of
life so now we're in the Natural Stone
section and this wasn't even anything I
was really considering because like I
said I already had a mood board and my
mood board now seems to be very B and
basic to me once I've seen I thought
move boets nice blet blend because all
of these are [__] sick so they're
Natural Stone meaning these things are
grown within
mountains um and then they pull these
Stones off and they polish it they make
them look like not like a manufactured
brick or something yeah these are just
one of a kind type of patterns and
colors like it yeah they can't just make
more than one yeah it took a hundred or
thousand years to create it yeah natural
means so these were like my basic ass
yeah
yeah desires I thought they still look
cool so mind you I want one in our
bedroom cuz we have a fireplace in there
and I want something in our living room
cuz that's the center piece of the house
and it's going to make the biggest
impression on anybody that comes in and
I just I like the way our previous house
that had Stone looked it was just such a
a beautiful art piece to have in the
house it is like an art piece you're
right it is Art um and because it's
alive like quote unquote alive or
natural it feels like there's movement
like it has an energy yeah like it feels
like it's like a different version of a
tree you know what I mean versus like
bricks just feel like oh like it's like
plastic yeah we made that put that up
but then it feels like a a piece of
nature is in your house well and and uh
and brick they make those yeah
manufacture um so like these are some
things that I'm looking at now so the
bedroom is going to be moody so meaning
like darker colors um that's the room
that I want the energy to kind of like
chill out bring it down let's let's even
have let's be a little bit more sensual
in there oh [__] okay I knew that word
was I knew that word was going to get
you but yeah like that's what I want it
to feel like I want you to feel warm and
cozy and like some [__] fest is about to
happen I'm just kidding oh
[__] you should have seen his face oh
[__] um I love get sensual whereas in
the living room I want it to feel very
Lively and happy but still very also
cozy and warm and earthy and have that
like energy of like hey this is where
you need to be right now chill out take
your shoes off enjoy the beautiful
scenery CU as you know our living room
has like a bunch of natural light and a
bunch of windows so you can see and
there's mountains back there yeah so you
can see the mountain you can see um just
the world on the other side or the
natural world on the other side um so I
really want to pull that out so being on
this side I already saw
this and look at this this is what I'm
talking talking about if you zoom in it
just looks like a bunch of little
crystals like yeah it comes it feels
like there's life in it this beautiful
so this is I wasn't even considering
this for the living room but now I'm
considering this for the living room cuz
look at all these natural colors yeah
like natural imperfections imperfections
yeah kind of like the moles on your face
um what another one I mean I love all of
these
honestly look at this one yeah look at
the texture in this rock look at this
right here can you see the shiny wo yeah
it's crazy how's this stuff even formed
that's insane what do how do I pick just
one that's crazy like how do they even
like how does this stuff just form
nature is nature is beautiful
spectacular
incredible wow look at this it's like
ta's room needs something
though everything marble and stone the
whole house look at this the walls just
cave in cuz so [__]
heavy okay so far I think what I
personally like is this one based off
everything that we've seen and the
reason why
is we're trying to fill this space right
and we have this really cool chandelier
that has like these like gold/ brass
elements and everything is like like
neutral white cream and I I like the
warmth of this first of all I also like
the yellow Accents in there and I think
it brings out the brass and the
bronze and this will be a continuation
of kind of like where our kitchen is and
I feel like it gives it like a little
pop on this side cuz everything is so
muted on this side so yeah this would be
we'd be sitting here looking at the TV
and we would see that so I feel like it
gives it like and it ties in like even
like the wood elements because of the
same color family so this is where we're
at but I also like this
one and these aren't even like what me
and Mama discuss is just what I
personally like I like this one too but
this one ties in a little bit more of
like the Grays and stuff so it brings a
cooler element not as warm but I like
the random
like like Grays of it I think that's
pretty
cool so kind of
stuck tell me about it dude so what it
seems like me and Mom are going to do
now is originally we're going to do this
project ourselves but I think we're
going to hire our interior designer
again because there's so many options
like coming here Andrew blew our brains
like I think we're thinking like this
small and now we're like wa so I think
we need to bring in someone with more
knowledge to take advantage and maximize
like what our house could look like so
stay tuned because this is episode one
of making our living room Ed looks sick
in episode two you're going to see us
decide what we want and then finally the
install of how sick it's going to
look